all right and we are live welcome to the
iron Lord podcast episode number 97 and
it's another glorious Sunday we're back
at the roundtable on the Lord's Day I'm
extremely excited about our special
guests so we gonna get right into it
I want to introduce the Lord who we
first got the opportunity to meet at PAX
East 2018 at the time this law was not
only holding on to one of the most
highly anticipated q4 release dates for
the Xbox and PC platform but it's
passionate for film and ultimately game
design truly resonated in a cooperative
love letter to Souls fans everywhere and
sure don't say the CEO of Aurora 44
studios and Game Director of the action
video game franchise the initial artist
by train and one of the very few Lords
to rock the ILP seal of approval t-shirt
with the utmost staff live from New
Zealand and making his debut into the
realm of the Lord's MAME Lord Eric
Bradley how you doing sir hey I'm good
thank you really happy to be here with
you guys absolute pleasure been long
overdue you are Lord in your robes only
right we show you the proper respect
here at the round table
are you ready have some fun sir
absolutely I know that you already know
we have the four horsemen again actually
five horsemen of gaming those Lords of
the realm here at the round table
my co-host would the Col most my brother
from another mother the difficult
getting Conqueror and the half of the
young
mommy doing pretty good coming here
today I will be joining a king in the
fraud department okay you did you fraud
are you fronting no we go there people
at home he's calling it now Friday he's
gonna be doing so we wait for King name
we wait for King man yes I'm meeting
starbursts I'm good we have our most
technical Gaming Lord the solo gamer who
lives for the single player selfish
experience and also the sastra darkness
mister o flower profile
and Lord patron of the iron bank mommy
Lord sovereign how're you doing sir
under a good man I'm really sick
[ __ ] I told you guys remember you
said as I was saying I'm doing much
better
I've been under the ropes the whole damn
week and also I got to rest today so
Thank You Derrick Thank You New Zealand
I appreciate that
you like the dude time zone switch yeah
today yeah and yeah I've been playing I
finally finished Leon's a story and
rebels I did that and I got to touch on
some Kingdom Hearts oh yeah a little bit
listen man I gotta say I think all of us
and this is includes Resident Evil 2
we're just fans of like poor acting and
video games I have to say like it's
pretty horrible that OH
I mean Leon is oblivious he's he's just
a dumbass and like it was cute 20 years
ago where does address later it did
update well and then Kingdom Hearts aw
man some of that voice acting and it's
just not oh it's painful it's pain if
there's one franchise I want Disney to
really jump in and like grab up and like
and and and piss people off of it and
control completely I would say it'd be
that no I never played the other ones so
I just wanted you know again um Kaiba's
who got it so I said let me play it let
me try this out you know and like listen
the the spectacle of it is great like
the boss fights it's a beautiful game
but to me they don't do enough with that
like that's a game that every kid should
be talking about so
I babysat my five-year-old nephew
yesterday and I said have you heard of
Kingdom Hearts week you know Mickey
Mouse Donald Duck Goofy's like no I
never heard of that and I'm like see
that's the mistake I know it's it's the
end of a trilogy and I know it's an S
square enix RPG but I feel like no
matter what you should try to market
that to as younger population as
possible Glenn played half that game
it's not for kids use of those
characters I think about that life a
good use of the characters because they
were trying to get the characters to
resonate with older players I can make
Mickey make that cross so when to work
in a sense because he's feverish Atticus
feverish about this game is a very
revenue and of course we have the
Incredible Hulk of this aka the XS gamer
ooh
the lord of combat sports who is a man
of his convictions demands nothing less
than that premium experience and is the
leader of the fraud alert movement ooh
beloved Lord King how you doing sir I'm
doing fantastic first of all I'm no
combat talk for that cold or fight
because y'all know I'm gonna go in on
them and I don't like to say bad things
about bad people baby but you anthem
boots oh boy okay first of all that game
has terrible wards terrible wards and
isn't a just you know the warts that you
can overlook because the warts keep
popping up every time you start having
fun and you got to go inside a closet
like if you see a closet over there to
play holdup watch this loading spring
real quick
and then you got it away and then your
fun is broken up then you get in there
but you gotta wait for your whole team
to do the load
stuff too and then they get it in and
then only just a turn back around
because it was absolutely nothing in
that room to go to another spot to do
something else and I said wow it's a lot
of break in the fun and then when you do
the stir hub the hub world is horrible
Tarsus or Tarsus your main issue yeah
that that is it's a lot of issues with
the game and we knew going into this new
IP that there will be stuff that they
would have to flesh out what I'm saying
because I've noticed a lot of people
champion again now you want something
different it gives you something
different remove the movements and the
sheet and the verticality in the game is
fantastic what it does do it does it
great oh very well
right and it's unique in that aspect but
the warts itself are hurts the game and
I don't think people attention span is
going to stay enthused with this game
for very long I mean a lot of people go
bonkers but are they gonna stick around
when other games of the same dope is
doing the better they make return is
longevity yes my main concern is the
meat of potatoes of the game if you're
giving me a game for $65 and there's
another game on the market or two games
on the market that has the same $65
cachet to it right and giving me more
meat what is what is my incentive to
stick with this game is like you know
you're getting water and soup you don't
feel like a whole full feature set oh
you know what you do don't you King mmm
you hit a pony if that review coffee I
definitely don't want to spend the money
for it
mmm all right that's one thing did you
cheat King is that the issues that
refine it no I don't think I don't think
I think the pricing in the game should
have been tiered to like a free-to-play
type of thing and then they can work a
model around it while the game builds
mmhmm right that's why I just think that
type of game that game itself is would
lend more to like warframe nope
how warframe did it okay to build up the
community that's what I feel
yes I'm gonna say on this cuz I know you
wouldn't need the line of fire on
Twitter would anthem he's like going on
with you these people have been attack
me over anthem over the epic game store
over Kingdom Hearts like I've been
getting from every direction but I'm
still wanna know okay okay King what
you've been playing besides and that's
it oh man um I got okay I got the demo i
played i played ashen so i don't be a
fraud
alright so let me tell you this right
I'm winning that's it CEOs on the show
no no no we met him we spoke to him and
then his representative from the new the
next time we went to pax
and at the Microsoft Convention Center a
guy treated me fantastic so I said
alright let me try a little bit harder
because before when I was playing the
game I was getting further I'm not
really fantastic in those games right
but that's all oh yeah I sat down I
noticed one thing the issue that I had
before with it we'll talk about it later
but um it I think they send an update to
it I want to accent my question because
my buddy you do this with me
oh he's working out this time like he
was actually in the mix with me because
I was getting jumping he came he was
like oh I got you to worry about thank
God look Derek can you attest to idiot a
I in recent a I improvements
how recently talking like how BIG's the
gap since you play it all right from day
one when it came out I played that whole
week right and no I'm not a Souls do but
I think has a different feeling so he
got killed though yeah you know how you
got the dude come on man and then when
you get a boss oh forget about it your
skills better be dodge worthy and but um
that I was having a problem with the AI
guys then because sometimes it gets
stuck at a door yeah
in or if I go down he will pick me up he
be standing around me and just won't
pick me up and then I dot with but this
time
this dude was on his P's and Q's he had
his Wheaties he was on it he was like
yeah we're gonna get past his lover she
was working I got the big stick if you
look when we went to pax one me and kid
played if you look at that uh that game
play you hear me in the back I said okay
kid drop the lantern drop the light the
kid drop the lexer improvements to the
AI just kind of before the team we don't
like you know the end of your holiday
right we put out a bunch of updates and
we've been working on a bunch of updates
again you know just to keep supporting
the game and like reacting to what we
see people through out there yeah that's
awesome good to see the support where
they slack King and of course we have my
fellow IT brethren and proud member of
the PC master-race
the discord chat police in Wilda of the
strongest band hammer you will ever see
leader of the street king mommy
lore penny are you doing sir hey how is
everybody doing man
pretty good oh what you've been playing
as fantastic week all I've been division
I've been trying to finish up my comms
trying to get everything done for
getting ready for division 2 I've been
doing what you're doing my you know the
regular Warcraft race is the new one
just came out I played some mash into
this week played that I plan in launch
week to the epic store did you have to
do some coding yeah you know cuz I you
know word is so difficult to just to
open up another launch girl you know you
know all that gray where are you
emotionally okay from opening onto
another launcher you know I was I was
okay and then I realized that fortnight
installed so I uninstalled that damn
and then I downloaded a [ __ ] I was ready
to go I was like this is great we had to
do some coding no I did nothing of the
sort
then without fede that's a good debut
Darrell and of course thank you got the
loaded cooperative experience and gaming
ninja himself the shinobi lore kognito
spreading that realness in the realm of
the ILP not telling you what you want to
hear which you need to hear from [ __ ]
is nothing but the destiny - last word
quest trying to get that done obviously
a touch the anthem or public demo
brushed up a low action prior to Lord
Derek's arrival
you know but oh that's pretty much it
for me mess up a little bit see what
they changed you know but we gotten into
what the Lord's have been playing I want
to start off with Lord Derek his video
game system history his journey and
video game design and what eventually
led him to become the CEO of rule 44 and
creating that critically acclaimed
action franchise so let's start from the
beginning Lord Derek like what was some
of the first video game systems you had
and what got you into gaming all right
now we're gonna deep today
[Laughter]
yeah one of those so it would have been
like at least things would be like Mario
Brothers Bomberman stuff like that yeah
I like I didn't have anything for a
while and so I got the Sega Master
System so I was playing like Mortal
Kombat world now I remember these game
yeah yeah like ice climbers stuff like
that and then I think I just got i got
into PC gaming pretty pretty big so it
was stuff like fallout one and two
was gay original nice quake things was
actually probably what I played with
most growing up to be honest and that's
like what maybe what again to making
games doing that kind of stuff I was
probably those games so you pretty much
after those initial system you pretty
much done a dog right into PC pretty
early did sort of spit yeah pretty early
I think it was literally my parents just
didn't like one of my consoles or
something and but they needed like a PC
you know like my dad was an IT though
you need a PC for stuff so I just kind
of backed on that nice salute slew the
dead say saving money being frugal we
respect that you know that was pretty
good I think
and recently I think what I've been
playing recently it's kind of tough you
know when you're making games you kind
of like it absorbs you so much then like
you you actually stop playing games or
at least at least during ship you know
like the last six months there is it's
so focused on what you're doing
mmm I definitely played I tried out the
anthem
panel is very cure impression well-liked
first impression right and this is like
really super special stuff was the look
of like the the town like the hub that
yes yeah it was pretty beautiful like
looking at like the volumetric lighting
and just like the feel of the whole
place I got a kind of like an aged one
way but there I got aside now what
platform were you playing this one this
was on the Xbox one X okay cool just
what they don't clarify continue sir
continued yes so no look really
beautiful it was quite amazing like I'm
kind of curious to see how much they
actually go into like the cultures and
all that kind of stuff of the world as
they get into it I had the same sort of
issues live like really long loading
times I think the first time I played it
like I going into a game loaded for a
long time I was like maybe that's the
load good and then I played for a bit no
idea what even happened and I was like
okay I wanna go
like you'd like fix up my suit do some
stuff and then it was just like a really
long loading time mhm I was kind of done
name but I played again yesterday it was
pretty good it was interesting I agree
completely about like the verticality
being interesting I like that you kind
of like a giant waterfall and like slam
into the ground the way you can boost
around and stuff is pretty cool
mmm absol yeah I really like the comment
I thought the comment about it being
like suggesting free to play for that
title is a really interesting comment
because you know traditionally like the
knee-jerk reactions are free to play is
like these guys are trying to make money
or quests or do stuff like that right or
like you know Luke boxes things like
that but I think the I think the whole
free-to-play model is kind of maturing
in a way where I think you're quite
right like there's some games that would
benefit from free-to-play and actually
give the community more but I suppose
it's like the developers perspective you
know I mean no matter what the model if
they go out to seduce it you know
they're gonna they're gonna do that yeah
I agree interested in how to mindscape
and everything the landscape is actually
changing and um you had to see who you
know which devs and stuff adopt it you
know kind of thing and we interested for
a game like anthem so that's cool did
you get a chance to touch that um so as
far as that I know you know you thought
you talked about that you talked about
going in a PC game and all that good
stuff and then I want to kind of focus
on you know obviously because of the
timezone I could sit a lord Derek you
you're in the future right now you're a
day ahead of us the exact Monday for you
so I can you briefly describe like how
gaming culture is and like New Zealand
like just in general like a mini gaming
culture yeah I would say it's honestly
pretty similar to the States
people are very into consoles there's a
good hardcore PC like yeah I would say
the trains here very much follow North
America pretty closely okay
which is kind of good for us running a
game studio you know we're kind of
plugged into the same the same stuff New
Zealand in general as it as a as a
culture and as a country is very kind
online savvy I guess you could say like
we buy a lot of stuff like online from
overseas for example like as a country
Kiwis kind of travel a lot it's just
sort of a thing like people traveling
about other countries and like you know
go to Europe kind of States go to Asia
is very very common so people are quite
connected in that sense and I suppose
that's why they're quite viacom percent
of what's going on in gamer culture and
quite plugged in to the North American
scene I would say good perspective so
long now that we got like that covered
as far as it was the only aspect and
just what I focus also on you start like
because obviously like people out do
don't know you you like obviously have a
little bit of artistic background as
well as and like then led into like the
texture artist aspect so um what kind of
got you into like that whole 3d modeling
and that aspect of gaming you know I
remember the like I studied film and
philosophy when I went to university and
I finished and I wanted to work in games
like there was all I wanted to do but it
was kind of it's not really kind of
qualification yes exactly and I think
the the thing was it was almost like you
know like you finish high school or
whatever ends like you're doing this
thing but you almost don't believe it
you could never get a job in games and
there's almost like being in New Zealand
there aren't really many game studios
and the ones they are I'm necessarily
making the games that I that I played
you know and so there was just a sort of
perspective of like I don't know if he
could really do it but while it was in
university Peter Jackson was filming the
Lord of the Rings around me and so that
was kind of happening around Wellington
and by seeing that happen you were like
no somebody can actually like do this
stuff like this kind of thing is real
and by achievable and so I try to get
like jobs in film it wasn't necessarily
my thing to be honest and I very quickly
decided to do like a one year course
just learning how to be a 3d artist and
again mostly like I don't I don't think
I necessarily wanted to be an artist I
just wanted to work in games gotcha
but it was good like I've done up my
whole life so it was a good kind of way
through and so as soon as I finished
there I go to joven games and as an
artist and I worked for a couple years
doing that I still wasn't sure whether I
wanted to do film or games you don't
really know until you do it so I like in
your middle with which your decision at
that point yeah it's sort of in the
middle and you kind of don't know and so
like games is really amazing it's like
it's like you're putting this life thing
into like even bigger a live ecosystem
you know and kind of seeing how it works
and all that kind of stuff but when I
got into its a film it was a bit
different it's a little bit more static
you know you put something onto a frame
and it's stuck there forever and then
you just move on to the next thing you
almost forget about it with games it's
almost like a curse and a blessing that
like anything you put into a game it's
alive it's reactive it could also be a
bug but you know so you're gonna support
it but it feels alive and there's
something really satisfying about that
that I really missed once I moved into
into the film which you know I really
appreciate it felt it was it was a
learning at winter digital was a
learning experience in terms of what to
do to achieve that professional quality
so team that will added quality and
seeing that heaven has been a bit of a
guiding light at the same time so I
definitely appreciate the timing games
to kind of learn the ropes the time and
film to get their perspective on yeah
it's a professional quality and then
kind of wanting to leave that to go back
to games but not having any game studios
in new zealand they did quite what i
wanted to do so my options were
essentially start a studio or go
overseas and find a job somewhere else
you're literally transitioning so my
next question because i would ask you
that obviously because we know the
climate of um new zealand and then you
know a lot of people don't realize like
i know from a big business standpoint
that's a that's a big deal so like give
me that whole mindset like basically you
took the leap of faith right like
basically you you left our
well-established kind of with a New
Zealand entity what was it what a
digital that's what it is
that's like Peter Jackson's sort of does
all the visual effects but there's lots
of maybes yeah yeah like you left this
like really established entity and then
took the leap over and then become a CEO
of an independent game studio so big
deal like put me in that mindset to just
put all your chips or the table just say
you know what this is what I want to do
it yeah it was like I remember coming
home one day I just deciding there was
it like and it didn't really matter
whether we succeeded will fail it was
like this is something I have to do you
know I really think it was just one of
those personal things you know where I
just knew like I really wanted to make
games and like I say you want to when I
graduated out of university and did all
that stuff you can get a lot of other
jobs you know they'd pay better than
being in games artist but you know put
another year into training just so I
could kind of get some basic skills to
be able to get a job and there was
literally all just because I wanted to
be in games and so the same thing with
this it was just you know people kind of
asked me like like you know what's my
end game with having a games company you
know because some people want to be like
hey I can have a nice house a nice car I
can you know one day you like live on a
beach I'm going to do what I've always
kinds of things and my response to them
always is like this company is my boat
you know this is the thing like when I
retire people have those like dreams of
like when I retire I'm gonna do
something mine's just like I'm not gonna
retire and so like this is sort of like
a very I kind of necessarily understand
it but there's a very like deep need to
do this thing and love it a game we
respect that yeah that's really cool so
um yeah I want to get to now actually
the fun part you know and um a lot of us
while we're here you know and obviously
it's the creation of ashes right
and both Tamar said like making the
souls like that hi
risk high reward in gameplay style and
then also explained to someone who may
not be familiar with the lorda game you
know it's far it's like what's the whole
you know thought process for that
creation of the of that game oh yeah
sure I mean I can start off by just very
quickly summarizing Ash and say everyone
knows what we're talking about some
degree so yeah it's got stamina based
combat which as you mentioned that like
high-risk high-reward what that means
essentially is that you have stamina
that runs out as you use abilities so
you can't just spam abilities you can
dodge and do stuff like that but
essentially the high-risk high-reward
comes from the fact that within the
genre enemies generally take the same
amount of hits to kill as you do so like
you know you'll take four hits and
you'll die they'll take four hits and
they'll die but then there's two of them
so you know you're gonna really break
their pattern apart
you can even necessarily like rise above
them because which is kind of like a
hallmark of the genre and so besides
there it's an open-world game so you
know you can kind of run around or
tackle things from multiple directions
where you know generally the genre is
all about like these very tight dungeon
puzzles which we certainly have a few of
those in our dungeons but when you get
into the wider world you can kind of you
know you can jump off the cliff and like
jump into some enemies you can
completely sliced it you can do stuff
like that and then these passive
multiplayer which is a bit like I
suppose games like destiny games like
journey when you just run past people
and they'll kind of connect to you
automatically in the background and that
all gets collated in the background yeah
and so that's like the basics of fashion
we want me to go with this like look
duck isn't how we can it's the idea -
part 2 part I guess the first part is
obviously the aesthetic right the
aesthetic of the game is really
beautiful very unique so one part of it
I want to know like how did you catch
Microsoft's attention right like how did
that happen as far as like you know them
approaching you you were like a tee
through the 2015 I believe correct yeah
yeah but I think this way if you were
like way back and I was like okay this
looks cool and then so I like that whole
process of them saying okay you know
what this looks cool I do they approach
you like how does that work with
Microsoft and Phil's like hey we want
this on our stage it's glue tube to us
okay that's actually an interesting
story it's pretty cool so we originally
put out a tweet which was just because
we were artists there were two two
artists one program essentially and so
we had a lot more going on than code and
code kind of takes a while to any right
to build up that whole platform it
doesn't really show itself so we worked
on the look and we put out a tweet which
pen to show the general vibe before we
were doing and somebody contacted us
from Microsoft just based off that and
must have been like done like I think we
got I think we got an article in Kotaku
mmm okay places they kind of feature
that awkward so Alexi Kovarian who was
at I need Xbox at the time and so we
heard from Alexi and he got in contact I
counted me but it was through Twitter or
through just just finding our email
address and like emailing contact but I
remember getting his email and being
like is this some kind of scam this
point we were like people who like we
lift our jobs sure we moved out to the
countryside like you know Wellington in
itself is the city of just a couple
hundred thousand people and we moved
like three notches away from that over a
mountain into a town of like two
thousand people out and out of the woods
so we could you know your rent was cheap
you can have a really nice environment
you can still afford like a bigger house
but it didn't cost you much because we
were just really focused on making a
game and in microsoft's contacting you
directly
it seemed out of control and so he was
very supportive and you know like i was
like we gotta call them and stuff and
like figure it out okay but
is definitely not like so try Samuel
it's real a year from then actually to
like sign anything necessarily and I
remember I'm trying to think of the
timeline but I feel like it was two
months before III then we actually
signed like a deal with Microsoft which
really set us up it was supposed to drop
a bad ball if you drop the bag and so
there was like a really good experience
you know like and it's it's kind of
amazing how much support Microsoft keep
giving assets
it's crazy route like we've been in III
twice as a first game like on the
Microsoft stage is just out of control
like you couldn't you can say to
somebody hey we're gonna quit our jobs
today with in like a year we're gonna be
on the Microsoft stage and you know
there's not even the first time you're
gonna do it you're gonna do it again I
mean that has to feel good especially
you taking that leap of faith such like
that I mean especially quitting a job
you know family relationship that kind
of deal you know that's a scary time so
we much respect you know for you to
chase your dream like that and just like
in such a short time boom Microsoft
stage or the crystals in the quality of
the game like from if the CEO is
dispassionate right and he puts all his
chips on the table it shows the quality
of the game my question is this right at
what point in time because this meant a
lot to me that it went from text-based
to everything this voice acting all of
that is acted is there like even you
talk to an NPC that's there they even
have stuff to say I guess everybody has
something to say and I think that is is
that yeah like your movie groups or
something like that they decided to make
their choice because a lot of times its
text-based instead of voice acting and I
think that the voice act and actually
you know boost the quality of the game
to be honest with me I agree completely
like you know the things that we did
like we did a bunch of play testing just
to see how people reacted to the game
and it was really interesting like it as
soon as we put voice after game like
people follow the story so much more
people with so much more engaged I think
this is like a dislike a the thing that
we do and it's like there's a difference
between I suppose casual izing a game
and making a game more accessible and I
think that voice makes the game more
accessible and that allows people to get
more absorbed and like by that I mean
like we work so hard on accessibility in
terms of like you want your newest gamer
who's never played this sort of game
like to have a pathway in words but you
also want the most hardcore gamers to
not be disenfranchised by the stuff you
do so it's like making that stuff
accessible on all levels is so key and I
think the the voice acting was just such
a clear piece where I think you're right
like we started off thinking hey like
there's a lot of games it just takes
maybe just to take so it doesn't matter
so much but it seems we tried like a
little bit of voice and like we just saw
people engage immediately and it was it
was so strong that all of that yeah is
this great - cuz he's like I have to
really respect that like you know there
is a difference between casual like
something and making it accessible and I
feel like a lot of gamers confuse that
yeah absolutely that's that's a big
point I think I'm glad you did cuz I
wanna we gotta get a little controversy
for Lord Derek so full disclosure Derek
I'm you know I'm a huge fan you know the
environment
art style even need the stylistic light
back with the feature facial features
you know I think that's unique the thing
is I have to be honest I've been on
record for being very critical
borderline emotional of the
implementation of the cooperative
experience so what I would like to know
is I like the idea of passive
multiplayer like you have at the top
toggle it off and on for that emergent
experience but what really bothered me
and like Lord addicts that I couldn't
CMAs Lee Joon a chess game without the
use of like the Franco
so can you explaining the design choice
behind not being able to use like my
xbox live friendless to just play with
whom I want or maybe just even having
like the gamertag option over there
heads above the character in the game
sure yeah so like not showing people's
names is a bit more of an easy one I
think and that's mostly because we
wanted to keep the whole experience
immersive I think like the way we could
potentially adjust something like that
in future games would be something like
if you invited a frame you would see
their gamertag but if a random person
ran past you you wouldn't so that you're
not seeing other people's kind of
influences come in and influence your
game necessarily but I don't think
seeing your friends is necessarily a bad
thing because you're already kind of
prepared for that
mentally definitely one of the things
that I that's come up and like post
mortem for myself it has been a key
thing for us is is like friend invites
stuff like that is super important so
that's something we're carrying forward
into future games I think with Escher
that's just like the inherent
architecture of the whole thing was so
skewed towards this passive multiplayer
system there would have been very tough
to like retrofit that in afterward but
certainly watching players play all that
kind of stuff like that's an absolutely
key key thing for us I would say and I
completely agree with you yeah because
it really depends like if you're in a
different zone so the players is in
location in the world like if one of you
is on the east coast once the west coast
you would have to use the friend code to
bypass the zone restrictions and that's
just so the reason they're zone
restrictions are there is just when
you're connecting to random people
you're not going to get laggy
connections right so it's really like
peer to peer as far as sublet from the
connection yeah yeah so it essentially
what happens with it like it goes up to
the server and it finds who's right for
you and it appears you often in which
you go peer to peer after that and so
yeah definitely and that's the reason
why yeah the friend code would be
essential like if you happen to be in
different zones because they don't just
buy parts all app so you don't talk with
someone like in Japan you know and
you're in the States for example it
would be fine as long as you have the
frame code oh my god in in part two of
my emotional cooperate because you know
I can't let it go
so I actually like the character custom
creator right I think the whole thing I
can do my skin tone oh hey continue all
that good stuff
but like I guess the other s right I was
like why can't we see these cool
customizations of the second player
while in coop you know saying cuz I love
Bradley you know Derek I need Lord
addict deceiving in all my glory he
couldn't see me as far as that like is
it just a multiplayer thing the
component that we couldn't get the
second player to be visualized as in
their custom creator no I mean like
honestly I'm getting the second player
to be visualized as they are would have
been easier what we did the real reasons
for that was like you know the base of
the game was set up for and I guess like
especially as a smaller studio we're
like we've got to kind of pick our
battles and choose which which things to
prioritize which is you know again like
moving into our next game we're in a
better position again so it makes things
a bit easier but we very much
prioritized almost the single player
experience there kind of adding to it so
it was it was prioritizing those
connections with random people you don't
know necessarily which is also why like
you know not having friend advice and
stuff like that was something that
wasn't in the architecture early but you
know in retrospect would have been a
good thing I think in this case they
like because the idea like this general
like narrative idea of it is if like
your hell's asking you to do something
in town he's not just sitting there he's
actually going out of helping you
achieve that goal necessarily and like
if you imagine like because depending on
who's based you're tracking
that's what MPC will pop in say one
random person pops in multiplayer and
then like runs off in a different
direction they'll look like you're Kyle
was playing with you for two minutes or
something go go somewhere else then
someone else so like helpful for
building from somewhere else and it'd
still be him so like from the player's
perspective narrative Lee you don't know
where people are kind of weaving in and
out of your world the most important
part is that you're playing with that
NPC who isn't
in town waiting - waiting to get his
goods from you or whatever but it's
definitely an interesting thing and I
think like as we widen our platform of
like what the game is and like how many
features we can put into it will start
to accommodate that stuff a lot more in
future games because just definitely
like the response to players who like
when I play with each other more easily
speech all that kind of stuff is really
cool and we've been really interesting
and I actually enjoyed getting all that
feedback to be honest no I appreciate
you said that you know that was
definitely a big thing I mean I'm the
lord of cooperative experience so for me
it's a big deal and um I'm glad that you
guys are taking that feedback because um
you know in future action - we would
like we would definitely like to see
that we definitely would like to have a
more of a seamless cooperative
experience as well as being able to see
those customers age because I think the
customization is cool I like the
aesthetic you guys built like the whole
faceless thing the world without lying
everything is cool woman and like I said
just being able to see that and I
understand you guys are a smaller studio
so I do understand you what your point
is as far as prioritization and taking
care what the immediate needs article
came out and get it running but to see
you guys take that feedback is really
cool so I'm glad you addressed it I'm
out of my feelings now I'm glad you said
that so um also on the flip side and I
just want to talk now about you know if
the coop side is about game pass like
how beneficial is gaining path to a game
like ashen and that whole player
population oh it's absolutely amazing
like having so many players in the game
all the time is great and like you know
it's also good for like smaller games
like I was like you and this is really
good like Super Bowl and stuff like that
going so I mean like having game passed
is just so great for just the visibility
of the game and I mean like I say the
studio was made to not necessarily make
money you want to make games that people
are gonna play you know and game pass
these people do that so easily because
you know you might get game pass because
you want to play fours or something but
then the game that's here I'll try out
just bear in a tree solo it's literally
what it how ever long it takes to
download and then you can check it out
the sign if you
you know um it's really great yeah I
think I think it's pretty cool too yeah
so we got dad we got the UM the co-op
aspect and then um now let's get to what
like something like a city to you and
your studio is a pioneer of and that is
the decision to launch on PC and almost
exclusively to the epic store so we know
the epic store has been a gaining
traction as of late so can you briefly
tell us like the thought process behind
that as we see more and more huge games
moving to that storefront as well as any
support tools from the Unreal Engine in
regards to cross play so like we like
we've had a really good relationship
with everything from a very very early
stage I guess going back to like when we
first signed up with Microsoft we go
like through our first III did a showing
there and you know we like it was full
of feeling like modest amount of money
and stuff like that we had to run a
studio so I think we could we took the
team up to take five we're we're
currently we're at 40 that's sort of
wood and even 40s like a small team to
make a game like like create he's heard
everybody the team now and so yeah we're
getting closer to that magical 44 but
when we got back from e3 though if it
had also given us Unreal Engine give
grant which was great you know like to
know like in terms of like running a
studio it's not the hugest amount of
money but it really helped us out when
we were like you know when you're
setting things on it's really important
and since then they've given us a ton of
like technical support all that kind of
stuff they always make the people
available to us right from the early
days we've had calls with their their
tech team like how do we do passive
multiplayer using your engine like what
features are there and because we have
to strip stuff right back and kind of
remove a lot of the multiplayer stuff so
then put ours on top of it and getting
those experts to let you know exactly
where the best points to make contact
are there without you be spending six
months of our ID into it you know
kind of stuff late to us honestly having
a really good relationship with him and
when they came to us like you know about
being on the epic game story I think
there's a few things like I mean I I
love steam I've got a huge game library
on Steam all that kind of stuff but my
general thought on marketplace economics
is I think it's always good to have more
than one competitor could you please say
that again what what download is that is
that like a competition say can you
could you repeat that sentence one more
time Lord Eric yeah no literally is for
competition second I think I think it
applies to anything you know it applies
to like shoes the headphones anything
you know like having more than one keeps
everybody honest gives everybody more
than honest actually keeps everybody
competitive
you can see like as soon as epic
platform came out came up started
offering different stuff like then
suddenly like 88 well you can talk about
the 88 well I mean like you know we
don't really look at it that way
necessarily because a lot of the
decision making it went into that was
honestly our publishers and they get to
decide how they want to publish it but
we were definitely definitely on board
because again like philosophically I
think more than just like money it's
like now people need to worry about like
how snappy is their platform how well
does it run how long does it take to
launch for people to get into it you
know how how good is their friends list
and they they have to compete on all
those levels even though there's going
to be a few numbers that we see that are
like really important like Oh divs are
getting a bit of riff shear on the
cement like while they're doing it well
I don't know like as long as I could eat
I'm actually pretty good like because I
get to make games I respect but you know
it was definitely good and you know
honestly like respects of the people
that steam as well they do a great job
like they're the industry standard at
this point and like if they could coming
in and they're they're challenging it
very very very aggressive challenge and
okay King I hear you came keiki out of
curiosity uh I just want did you guys
expect you know any kind of backlash
from the steam community you're like it
but you know and I think there's like
the there's always going to be there
right because everybody's got a valid
perspective and like something like each
person like something specifics more
importance of them you know there'll be
companies for example where like the
reef shoes like all they care about and
that's like number one there'll be
others other companies that like you
know do it for all sorts of reasons and
I think when we look at the players this
is the same thing like some people would
be like why do I need to have another
launcher why do I need stuff that's not
going to be in my library and that's
like their number one perspective is
that and they want that satisfied and
this completely valid as well I think
this because you know we're all
individuals and games companies the same
way you know every games company has a
different personality so like me been
saying like we don't necessarily care as
much about the river here we care about
like how the platforms are going to be
challenging each other and like bringing
bitter experiences there's gonna be dips
who have different different focuses to
that as well but yeah and I guess it's
kind of like the beauty of the open
market you know is then those things can
now be satisfied in in multiple like in
different ways like some people might
like the way another one works the way
that one works but most certainly like
the backlash from the community is is
valid I mean that stuff needs to be
heard because that's how that's even how
the open marketplace works because now
that now the the the platform holders
are like how do we make these people
happy how do we satisfy what this thing
takes and it challenges they're like you
know when they had their dick in there
and their board meeting and they
presented like this perfect plan well
that doesn't necessarily take into
account what everybody needs hearing
that stuff is like I think that's key
for them to make like the right
adjustments and get it right you know
yeah I think you may develop because at
the end of the day it's like even if
you're trying to be compared
without you know average time compared
to what a storefront you know they have
to hear this feedback from a whole
community that may be upset that a she
goes over there and say okay well maybe
we don't like it's over there because we
don't like the feature set of the store
yet but this now intent and turn now
pushes epic to say okay you know what we
have to be have to now step up our store
options and the things that we provide
so that we can compete and make it more
viable today if people want to come over
they have the same experience and you
know a lot of their future said that
they have before you know with every as
well so it's actually a very good point
and I'm glad you actually a cognizant of
listening to the community and then
their you know their feelings as far as
I'm being vocal about it which
transitions me to what I was gonna ask
you which was um you know as far as the
Windows 10 play anywhere crowd because
when Ashton was first announced I
remember this was a play anywhere game
like so as we got closer to launch she
was a cue for you know I know a lot may
have been disappointed I know myself
included initially that you know there
was wouldn't be no cross play at launch
with Xbox so I guess my question is
because of the exclusivity deal right
now with epic is there any updates or
announcements and if you shouldn't in
that regards to Windows play anywhere
and compatibility with the Xbox and PC
ground so like epic are really
understanding about that stuff we have
no limitations from them I think like
the donee reason that we have any issues
there it's just again being a small
studio trying to put things out on so
many platforms making sure that we hit
that quality bar on all the platforms
the fact is the biggest issue for us so
we're just taking like a little bit more
time because we wouldn't want to put
something out there like you know didn't
have some shade is working well yeah so
that's very much quality and I guess
that even that is like it's an
indication of how light competitiveness
is good because if if like epic were the
only game in town maybe there'd be like
no you can't do that and that's you know
that's kind of not there there mo in
general to be honest but you know the
competitiveness means that like things
kind of soften up a lot which is good
because I want people on the platform
they're gonna entice you to their
platform so stuff like yeah they
certainly have not gone in the way
that edible very supportive about it
yeah awesome so man it's good good stuff
so um yeah like I said you got that we
got the other epic thing we'll revisit
that little later okay
but um yeah the last thing is like the
um obviously the mindset of a studio
releasing a game you know the journey a
viewing this game all the way back into
2015
getting the release to the met like how
proud Lord Eric are you of the team do
you have like a sense of accomplishment
now that this thing is kind of like
you're in post-mortem like you know
you're in that zone how do you feel it's
finally here
well I remember walking off the stage in
2015 when we did our first trailer and I
was like I could get hit by a bus didn't
even have to like release the game
actually you know what stage at e3 I
think there was enough and I don't know
like releasing the actual game is is
quite surreal I don't know even now if
it's completely sunk in to be completely
honest it's it's like life-changing to
release your first game because games
are so high risk you know like there's
so many games that kind of just die in
development there's so many games
especially from first studios go
overreaching as we were you know it's
it's tough and yet there's no like
assumption that if we would have been
able to get there I guess I do have
another question um were you were you
guys always looking to you know make
that typical Dark Souls gameplay or was
that like you know off the the mini
attempts that you were looking at to
making what kind of game um different
like the syste we started off with it
was kind of like a high-level I suppose
would you call it like idea and the
thing that we did the pillar that we
kind of cling on to for like a whole
bunch of composite things that are
coming together front like sound to
narrative to a game play all that kind
of stuff coming to try getting to be
cohesive and that we angle it towards
stuff there was about forging
relationships so things that would would
make you closer to the people that you
play with
and then very just underneath those the
three things that we had was that we
wanted it to be open world so you can
choose your way through the world we
wanted it to be stamina based combat
that like high-risk combat so when
someone helped you it was meaningful and
we wanted it to have their passive
multiplayer just because it promoted
that kind of like natural way of meeting
people as opposed to meeting people
through lobbies and stuff like that
which is almost like a barrier we wanted
that but I suppose that's where the open
world nurse comes through to that it's
all seamless you know there's no loading
screens and stuff between you and your
experience that you're having with other
people so all of that was like really
early and so we did a pretty deep dive
into insanity based combat while kind of
streamlining things a little bit our
focus was very much just on finding that
like negative gold very deep inside
there like what is the thing that is
almost like invisible and it's not about
extra features it's just about how do
you do good stamina based combat was
kind of our focus let me open it up Lord
our PD and Lord saw of any other
questions or Lord Derick and reference
to action in his release it's often go
first mmm okay so um my specific
question is it's kind of about the lore
and the world and specifically the um
the literary inference influences that
you had um when I was looking up you
know the history of the development of
the game one of the things that came up
was that a big influence was Cormac
McCarthy and the road and McCarthy is
one of my favorite authors and
specifically the road after hearing that
comparison like yeah it makes sense
because the world is again the world is
like this darkened place that is in
essence covered in like something in an
ash like substance and it's like there
are a lot of comparisons there is there
besides that and and even going back to
the story of the road kind of that whole
idea of like bearers of the fire and the
light and things like that things that
came through sort of in the lore of
ashen in addition to like Norse
mythology sort of influences with like
the Tree of Life and like the nine
realms and stuff like that so where
where did all that sort
influence come from like who
specifically added that to like the
flavor of the game and stuff like that I
would say there was it's kind of tricky
to know where it came from specifically
I mean there was definitely something I
was into really early and the I'll tell
you in a bit like about it there's a few
more people on the team that kind of
somehow brought that same thing to but I
think you know for me like storytelling
specifically in games sits in in
features even more than it sits in in in
narrative so to speak where like the
option of giving someone the ability to
revive somebody else gives them the
ability to craft like an emergent story
with someone else or how you connect
with people how how you kind of
progressed through stuff it's almost
like that tool bag that you give players
to move through things and I think that
was probably for me where the road had
the most influence too because if you
look at the road it's all about like
what this for these relationships mean
when you like ride out on a limb you
know when like the whole world is kind
of crumbling around you and you've got
these like this one thing to hold on to
and I think that comes out in like
stamina based combat without with
somebody else in in in co-op it comes
out in these life you know you go into
those dungeons together in action and
you have to put your hands into those
halls I mean you're like seriously stuck
in there with one other person and if
that person dies you're like you're in
the darkness all by yourself you know so
it's holding on to that other person
tightly was kind of like as we built
those features up but when so I was
doing like some research and so like
blacksmithing and just seeing like the
the you know the proper ways things have
done because you could go do your
research and I was watching a video
about making I was making an axe or
something like that and they had this
music in the background and I was like
that music would fashion perfectly so I
got in contact with foreign fields who
Erik Hillman or Edith Hillman who ended
up doing our
soundtrack was one of the members it is
one of the members currently offer our
field still and the song that they're
done and when I started talking to him
about it he said he literally can't
remember where he was but he'd just read
the road and then wrote the song based
on the road so that one's all about like
carrying the light and doing all that
kind of stuff as well and was very
interesting because I didn't necessarily
click there's anything to do with that
but that was kind of like a very deep
influence for him and interestingly we
had like a interviewer kind of like
Christmas holiday get-together thing for
the team and he flew over from Nashville
to come and to come see us and the one
thing he did and our and our like team
gathering was play that song for
everybody and it was just like his thing
that he did and that sounds like not in
the game at all or anything but it's
sort of like deeply resonates I guess
and like permeates everything about the
game oh that's that's great so will we
ever get to hear that song is that a
personal thing for you guys that you
just get a good you can check it out
it's called names and races by foreign
fields amazing song like I would I
recommend a playlist like if you want to
kind of chill out and relax yeah it's
one other thing on that so did did the
road also sort of influenced that sort
of the faceless protagonist decisions
that you guys made in terms of the your
player character because again like in
that book like no one is named right
it's just a boy and his father that no
one in the book is named at all so with
that another influence yeah absolutely
I'm like you know so many things pointed
towards that all of us like I think
probably does like a similar thing we
like the boy and his father is it's
meant to be relatable to you as soon as
you give them a name if his names like
Bob or something that you're thinking
about Bob you're not thinking about
Corey right it's not your story anymore
yeah exactly
there was the reason for faceless
characters in in action and I mean I'm
not sure whether or not we would do do
that again even you know because it was
something that flipped this game so well
the same as you know not showing what
other people look like necessarily where
it's other people get to essentially you
know if you want to take it so like the
father and the boy it's like other
people get to play the boy for your get
to play the father for you they don't
get to play themselves necessarily in
action it's very sort of like
high-concept thing which kind of matches
this this game yeah fair enough
Lord Acton got any other questions for
Lord Garrick oh I didn't have one I was
thinking about when it comes to you know
features that you won't necessarily was
able to put in Ashton - is there
anything that you guys are you know test
it around with but either you know
limitations or you just couldn't get it
done in time oh really I mean like I
think this one came together really
tightly to be honest like certainly the
like the friendslist stuff would be but
it was more like in retrospect you know
because you almost can't tell what it's
like when you when you you're too close
to it for so long you need to like watch
other people play it was really
interesting and you need to watch other
people play it from like so many
different perspectives to even pick that
kind of stuff up whereas even when we
did like play tests you know they had
too much support around them I suppose
like they had too many people around
them they were like if you get stuck
just do this so that I could like move
them through the play the play tastes
once you get like the community's kind
of raw feedback that's just super
valuable for developers but I think what
else there is
I mean there's definitely stuff we would
have we would have done more with you
know we would have done more open-world
stuff we would have done more like
features out there are things but I mean
you start to get into like almost like
Assassin's Creed hierarchies or like
Nemesis systems you know I got uploaded
but it's not a budget though I'm
definitely like the Lord that plays more
Souls inspired games and I have to say
like Ashton is definitely one of the
unique ones out there
that kind of you know Stan I'm a reward
risk factor gameplay because there's a
lot of things that you know it did
really well and you obviously it was it
was highly critique and I just want you
know it was it was a pleasure playing
the game I definitely enjoy absolutely
thank you great game so uh before we get
to the poll and then our one singular
topic name we get a Lord Derek going but
uh last week's poll actually before we
do last leaf' I apologize I have to ask
the question after all the lords and
room all the guests Lord Derek I need
you top five games or video game
franchises of all time
[Laughter]
yeah I guess so I guess up for which of
three is the one cuz I mean they just
get better every time
Baldur's Gate which is three which is
which is all right when I fall out to
fall out oh wow that's unique that's
unique oh yeah watch you be given every
character over watch it's so basic just
like soldiers
I was literally just playing that I was
playing mercy like all morning
nice nice and double v franchise
absolutely fantastic five let's get to
the poll and then on one topic so uh
last week's poll results are in and the
people have spoken with the recent
example of the atom VIP demo how
concerned are you when developers
expressed as some specific aspects of
the game will be changed exclusively for
the demo prior to release the winner at
48% of the vote was fake outrage the dev
told you
what was in the game group covenant at a
close second at 35 percent was that I
said I don't care anthem server's still
get the jordan cry-face group they
coming in the last place at 17 percent
was the very concerned game demo does
not represent the real game group thanks
to all the lords who participated in
last week's poll Lord sovereign what do
you think about it I mean I think my
issue with it last week was that so
close to release I think they should
have given you a product that was closer
to what the final game was gonna look
like I just don't see a reason for for
for that much of a distinction between
what you're gonna get in a couple of
weeks and what you played it doesn't
make any sense of being that close to
release it because it gives people a
false sense of what the game is and if
it comes to things like I think Lord
brat mentions is balancing and stuff
like that that's very huge in in in a
game of this nature then yeah like it
has to be closer to the final product it
just has to be and you know I can see
people's outrage over it because that
determines whether the game gets
purchased or not right um if you if the
game needed a real beta which I think it
really did that but I think it needed a
real beta six months ago um I think that
would have been more beneficial to
people understanding what the final
product is gonna be what's your thought
process on games that like drop maybe a
demo before the release and you know if
the dev Khanna makes instructions to say
hey these certain aspects might get
changed you know prior to the game's
release what's your thought process on
that it's like an interesting puzzle
actually because he's done weird games
that put about demos sell this really
Wow yeah I think and I think it's
probably because you know games are like
selling a dream and sometimes you buy a
game and you know you play it for a week
and you're like uh weekend I'm done you
know there was a movie ready for me I
bought the book into the dream and so
there might be like a third of the
people who buy the game would do that
and then they just get that out of the
demo anyway
mmm like they sampled it left yeah I
think that's true too because if you
notice throughout the past couple years
like probably the last five to ten you
really don't see demos at all anymore
mmm yeah good point good point like you
feel a pretty Yeti bigness a on that old
demo situation and I actually agree I
think that a lot of people that are
starting to play those demos and they're
kind of using them almost like testers
for their games that they don't like
them they're not gonna get them but you
know those people that love those games
and and love the franchises that you
know we're coming out the ones they're
gonna continue with them absolutely the
lottery robbery you said you had a
question real quick yeah I actually did
I actually had a question for Derrick
when when you guys were deciding to
build out the character customizations
and everything at what point were you
like we want to use those polygon fields
for all of the the objects in the worlds
because that that I feel is very old
school type genre of gameplay that I
love you know when I think of those old
polygon things like those fields I think
of you know Star Fox and all of those
old type of games and I love them and I
think they seamlessly worked very well
in ashen when did you guys feel that
that was you know the the type of track
you wanted to go with your with your you
know with your visualizations sure like
we actually started from the
environments in which to be honest and
like a lot of environment artists who
work is concept artists they actually
don't paint faces on their characters
and so it was like about this cohesive
picture you know like imagining ways
that a play if you almost like sit back
and look at the game and see it as like
an environment painting and and and have
them like immersive nature to it where
you're not necessarily getting
completely focused in just on your
character in those moments like you can
be looking out over a cliff and like
looking at the scenery and
the character doesn't sort of like like
the light up right in the middle and
draw your attention and there's so many
things that we do in this sense for
example the whole picture is actually a
little bit D saturated as you get closer
to the player there's actually more
saturation just because that's kind of
how your eyes work anyway it kind of
mimics that to some degree where your
peripheral vision actually sees less
color but we put a bit more color nearer
the player but as you move away from the
player is less just to kind of like
smooth things off this stuff like a lot
of games will have a light on the player
select the player will have their own
lighting to kind of make them pop and we
do like none of that so the player in
that environment and that's because we
went like environment first and yeah
like wiping the faces off it was
definitely like there were two reasons
for it the first was that we wanted the
the Cormac McCarthy thing to be one of
it that you're not judging a book by
it's cover and that you're and that
you're able to visualize yourself as the
characters and you're able to make your
mind up about the other characters as
opposed to telling you about them and
then the second part was certainly like
inspired by a lot of the great
environment concept artists out there
we're yeah as a cohesive whole the frame
doesn't necessarily always require a
face I guess the whole look that whole
like locally looked was something that
certainly came from the environment
first so he actually built the
environments before we built the
characters and my other question was
when being that this is such a large
open world environment how did you guys
end up like storyboarding it did you did
do you figure it out this is the path
we're gonna put four DS character for
this character and and go through the
you know with the darkness and you know
you wanting to you know essentially see
Savior people so it's kind of
interesting because you know a lot of it
was loose story that we came up with at
the start and then like allowed for
space for our like concept artists and
things like that to move through and
kind of add and stuff to but it's also
an interesting question because
making action and developing action was
a little bit like building a rocket ship
on the way to the moon you know you're
like you're hooking pieces on because
like right now we're a team of 40 when
we were a team of five we physically did
not have and so this piece is on what
they came in like halfway through which
is honestly like really exciting right
now because we've got like a whole team
with that full skill set ready to make
our next game is I'm just I have no idea
where it's gonna go it's gonna be
absolutely crazy in comparison
did he just say next game yes you just
said next game a potential sequel yeah
we look in the trouble room with an
action tuba we can't ask it may be
potential DLC fashion we'd love to do
that kind of stuff and you know then
really like comes from the response to
the community how much people want to
play the game more and certainly we have
seen like a very strong need for such a
thing talking about that okay so based
on the needs of the community they might
be discussions their trouble so uh let's
move on Lord saw I was gonna give this
to you I don't know I didn't know if you
could be a but initially about uh what's
going on in the world of the epic game
store and Metro Exodus have you been
paying attention to this oh yeah I've
been paying attention to it a little bit
would you like to bring everyone up to
speed is this our singular topic for the
day for you so uh basically what's going
on with the epic game store is that well
Metro Exodus as you guys will may know
about spend maybe about a week and a
half two weeks now that they've
announced that they were going to be
exclusive to the epics game store on PC
now the issue people have taken with
this is that up until this point
has been fully available to pre-order on
Steam mmm and other platforms I'm
assuming but I'm steamed is that the
primary platform rom and people have
taken issue with the fact that rather
than this be this is a deal that they
feel should have happened earlier on
before the big game even got to the
point where they were taking pre-orders
on any platform so that ink be
determined from the beginning where this
game was going to be sold and so um
there are some people will take an issue
with that and then apparently what
happened was that one of the game devs
got basically wrote a little bit of a
rant on Twitter that would that that I
saw that was kind of poorly translated
yes but generally translated to indicate
that he was threatening the PC community
saying that if they boycott this game
based on the fact that they decided to
go with the epic game store and then a
PC community could be guaranteed that
their next game would not be coming to
PC oh so and apparently there has been
some sort of response to this all over
the wasn't gonna I didn't hear the
details of it but uh-huh
so the the quartering which is a YouTube
website yes Aidid who kind of broke and
broke about the story yesterday um
indicated that they did receive some
sort of a response from from that
developer or specifically that that that
individual who who made that comment um
but I have not had a chance to see it or
what it entails or anything like that
but generally there are people who have
decided to flat-out boycott the game
because of the issue of the game coming
to the epic store especially so late
before at least especially considering
the fact that it had already been up for
pre-order on Steam again anything any
version of the game that was pre-ordered
on Steam before this announcement is
being honored so you will be able to
download it through Steam and play it
through Steam so let's get our lord
Derrick in on this because obviously
this the reason why I wanted to bring
this up obviously we don't want to you
know kind of like put you up against a
eight-ball what's going
what in the sense of the reason why I
felt you were the perfect guest to have
this topic is obviously like I said you
guys are the pioneers in my opinion you
know you were like one of the first
games that I've heard going to the epic
store and at the time you know I
wouldn't say wouldn't say receive the
the backlash that the Metro axis kitty
but there was confusion everyone didn't
know what was going on in there so like
what do you feel when you you hear about
this kind of thing and you know game was
very upset you know a lot of gamers are
very upset that uh Metro Exodus is going
over to the epic game store and um
generally as far as the developer
response as well you know like what's
your whole take on this situation in
general I think as well I actually think
it's all really healthy like I think
that stuff if you imagine like epic and
steam are gonna have like these very
professional approaches to stuff because
they've like been thinking about for
months they've got this whole
orchestrated plan as to how they want
these things like these moments to
converge right but now this will develop
is hooking into the platforms and
commenting from different angles at the
same time you're getting community
members hook into that and like respond
to all this kind of stuff and because of
that you're getting like negatives
thrown in you're getting positives
thrown in and wait something negative
happens I think that's only like an
opportunity to learn and figure out
something positive happens because I
mean like Dave's always want to put the
product out there and like make sure
it's in the right like it's gonna be
received well I mean like I think
universally so when something happens
the rest of the development community
can look at it and be like okay well
that's like an adjustment that we
shouldn't be doing that thing
necessarily but sometimes it's something
you haven't seen before or there's some
sort of dynamic to it so interesting
because I don't really know the
situation even saying that you can't
actually still get the versions of the
game that we're right now yeah let's
break that sort of pre-order the people
who who pre-ordered the game initially
on Steam that's being honored correct so
of and every pre-order on Steam that
went in before this deal was announced
is being on Oh
so as of now what is it about two weeks
before release or whatever it's been now
the deal has come to come to pass on the
light as far as it being exclusive to
the epic store right and the backlash
again we just want to clarify it's just
that people are upset that this is most
likely an exclusive to the epic store
for about one year correct oh please
you're right it's a one-year exclusivity
okay so it's a one so as of right now if
you want Metro Exodus you have to get it
do the Exodus I mean the epic store
unless you pre-ordered already on Steam
which would then be honored right okay
so that that's where we are currently
right now and then up until that point
Lord Derrick there's been a lot of
backlash on what's happened is games
like the prior Metro games have been
review bombed on Steam you know a lot of
fans have lashed out in reference to the
practice they don't like it being
exclusive there are other issue is that
the epic game store they feel is um not
as feature-rich now as they feel that
the steam platform is the better
platform as far as features and that
steam fabric shouldn't be doing this
unless their store is up to you know to
the same level so that that what do you
say to that to that and that argument
you know of gamers beginners it I think
it's kind of like a chicken and egg kind
of thing the games in there is the
platform if we're going to mature if you
don't have like the need or the people
criticizing the platform or asking for
what they want is the platform ever
going to mature and like epic have the
resources to do this thing like if
anybody in the world right now has the
resources to do it I think I think
there's going to be a teething period I
mean even just from like looking at a
div who is now like like just taking
this one scenario we like they plan to
go on the Steam and now there's a flip
and they're not on Steam they're going
to which is you know some of us we
didn't know we were gonna go on the epic
platform and so like feeling fairly cool
that was kinda similar to your situation
exactly yeah I think the issue is
they're like people can't really
orchestrate hey we plan to go on the
epics tour like no one knew that two
years ago
or anyone so because of that you just
couldn't physically orchestrate that
stuff in like a very elegant way which I
think you know Diesel's stop being able
to do that now like projects at the
beginning development now or maybe even
halfway through development now can
start to like move themselves that way
more smoothly and communicate that it'll
be a lot smoother but like this kind of
this point in which like if I have to
like rip the band-aid off we're still in
the band-aid riffing there every day
I got I got a question well I got what
questions we'll follow up with that what
he said I give it to you addict Oh as
far as now the developer speaking out
apparently allegedly the you know the
developer for a one of them were on like
a message board and I don't know if he
speaks Russian I the translation was a
little off but you know from what he
said you know I looked at did the
commentary basically what was put out
was that they said that he was
threatening gamers that if you know much
yeah that if they don't unprofessional
yeah if they don't you know by from
there
the epic store that you know it's going
to go away from the PC platform entirely
now as me looking at the translation of
what he said he basically was kind of
stating that um you know he knew that
this issue would cause with rejection
you know the need to move it to the epic
our launcher would cause some
inconvenience to the players and
therefore some disconcert but he says he
said he said he feels the reaction of
gamers is hardly adequate he said it
seems that the people did not want to
play just waited for a reason to pour
out their bio he said this as it turns
that we the developers for years have
been hard and painful with losses to try
to do something special for gamers and
he said but a category of play players
believe that our work is not even worth
a couple of minutes to install the
launcher
he said naturally is there right and
then he goes on to say you know
obviously he feels that the true gamers
is not that love their franchise this
would not be an interest to them but he
did say the situation get deeper and he
said that um anyone who's saying that
that they you know they don't like
Exodus and previous games and assists on
the series he said that um if all PC
players announced a boycott of the metro
phase
tries he said then the next Metro if it
does come is definitely not on the PC
better or worse decide for yourself I
personally feel sorry for the loyal fans
but my assessment of the work done
personally by me and my friends and
colleagues will not change this I firmly
know that almost everyone who pours this
dirt on the Internet is also incapable
of a bit of what we have done and
hopefully do more they don't know what
they're talking about so he was upset he
went off he went out on a social media
that you know to say that but um you
know what do you feel in that regard you
know obviously you're a dev you you
understand what it takes to make a video
game and um you know at the same time
you do it you're empathetic with the
with the you know with the fans of your
franchise like what do you feel about
this aspect of adult developer speaking
out to his fans you know it's kind of
tricky right because the developers are
a professional entity like and it's yeah
because because we're I think it's like
really healthy to hear all the excerpts
from fans I mean like that particular
developer obviously has something that
they value and like that's they're
setting them off you know to some degree
at the end of the day like you know I
think they're a good developer I think
they were passionate developer and they
got that it sounds like they're a bit
emotional about I mean I I feel like
they're very very like into the game
they're very tied to it they've just
finished like I know how hard shipping
is that like you essentially bleed to
that like nobody nobody escapes shipping
unscathed
so I kind of get that they could be
emotional and don't necessarily think
that they mean it in in that sense I'd
be curious what the translation is and
stuff but yeah even so like I'm I'm
equally hesitant to be like developer to
defend it as well because everybody's
got different perspectives you know each
developer is going to give you like a
different perspective with you I suppose
if you look at the bright side of it
it's like a good it's like it's a good
window into like just thinking what
somebody puts into making a game
I'm emotional but at the same time I'd
like I don't necessarily if they don't
buy ashin right now there's no more
action for you how the other metros will
review bond I think that made it worse
for them fast cuz those games really
didn't have anything to do with the
issue and they have gamers go out on the
you know to dishonesty look at P D in on
his back PT you've been weighing in on
this whole thing man what do you feel
about the whole metro Exodus C so I
think it's crazy number one that these
guys would be so unprofessional but to
do something like this mm-hmm but for me
when I went to buy action over the
weekend first thing I did was I went to
the Steve store and you do have a page
there it says coming soon just saying
and I was like alright it's not here
okay close that and then I opened up the
epic store it's like oh it's here I
downloaded it
I don't care where my games come from
III really don't care if they're in
library a or a library B or if I gotta
go to the store and still buy a CD I
don't care you know I love that game on
getting so you know what these guys that
that are being the way they are it's
just you know Internet trash to me mmm
would you would you guys agree that the
people that are outraged is you know I
would is is the small vocal people in
our team because I feel like the you
know for the most part the people who
just get on Steam buy a game and play it
you know they're gonna get all Metro
Exodus isn't here and then they're gonna
google it oh it's an epic store and
they're just gonna buy it what an I
think it didn't help that steam came out
and made a statement themselves which is
right and a kind of a regular I guess
that's something that they you you would
expect them to do you think Cindy knows
that this is going on before it happens
or you think they get surprised on on
Twitter just like everyone I don't know
that they got surprised by this I see
that's yeah that's an interesting
question because I don't think they were
surprised by this they knew and I think
they use fan
reaction to their benefit they did come
out with a statement right lost off
saying it right we felt it was unfair it
was unfair to the fans they didn't want
to focus it on themselves so they
projected it onto the fans and run with
it
hmm I got a question like it it's kind
of a scenario thing I'm kind of curious
Oh
okay when it comes to you know games
going over you know some have more
effect than others you know what do you
think is the one game that could get an
announce is going to epic but not steam
that would get people riled up the most
because I carry some because me
personally I think if Red Dead came out
and it was only on epic the Twitter's
gone ha ha like steams gonna crash like
people going so outraged but with a load
their go-to spot that I'm just curious
what he feels like you know is the is
the game that would just push it over
the edge I feel like that would the
vision wasn't as bad as this one like it
feels like when people are all okay the
divisions going over there okay but the
moment that Metro at Exodus got it now
it just felt like the Twitter blew up
yeah went crazy divisions got a
following man they're not they're not
gonna get all angry and pissy yeah I do
feel like that for the most part it is
only you know the minority like if
you're a fan like you know people have
been following ashen forever like oh you
got to go to epic and I do think since
it was an original title and it was your
guys's first game I think you you know
you you you got under that you know
those flames a little bit and you
because you know if he was like in the
Ashton three and ashen the reason why I
feel ashen also escaped a lot of that
vitriol was that initially was
understood like it was an xbox exclusive
I think it was more so looked as a
console game first and we knew it was
coming a PC but um oh no I just feel
like they escaped it a little easier
guys I don't think you did anything with
the division to I don't think they ever
that to my knowledge did did the same
issue happened that there were
pre-orders that went up on Steam and
then Ruby
when division came when division came
out on scheme and it's always been a
problem is that when their updates came
out they would get them hours later if
you bought them on Steam instead of you
play there was always a problem with it
so for them to walk away from Steam was
probably a great idea from them but I'm
sorry in terms of wouldn't you they
haven't been any issues wait like they
in terms of division to the the deal
with division to an epic was that's
something that happened way before any
pre-orders went up on Steam for that
game there was that there was never any
pre-orders on one scheme at all that was
never even a thought concept until you
know very recently so I think that
matters a lot yeah go go around the
round table what you got which which
game do you guys think would get to it
or more elder hmm I don't know man I
mean at this point I think just a
newness of what epic is doing is what
I'm saying is like epic like you know
epic has any choice of any game to get
the best following possible for epic
store what would it be what would you go
after oh that's tough I'm gonna give it
a go at first people being upset about
it though I think it's like a lot of it
is expectations right the more that you
expect this thing to be in a certain
place and now it's been shifted the
worse it is
so like games that are traditionally
gone so like a lot of platforms have
been exclusive so that kind of like
people have maybe more like I think read
did was a good cool yeah yeah I don't
think there's a game bigger than if read
that came out and it wasn't gonna be on
Steam like I saw people boycott destiny
to I've seen there's a couple of people
I saw go crazy over sinner sacrifice
Redemption I saw a couple and ashen but
like red dead I don't you want to see
Twitter I might have to log off Twitter
I would say I would say like cyberpunk
or the next people all people want that
style I think sobbing ailed it was the
CD Projekt RED you know Rockstar would
um what you call it I'll read there
because right there still hasn't made
its PC debut right
no yes you're right no wait right
because if epic was able to snatch that
oh and you know my part is is a steam
doesn't compete with epic and lower that
you know what the the you know the cut
is I think unless they're gonna make
their own launcher you could possibly
see Red Dead to go on epic only I know
what like like Lord Eric's it epic right
now has the the capital they ready to
back the truck up
you know they got that fortnight buddy
right right well my souls crazy
I wouldn't surprise guys saw but I want
to jump in on this topic mom yeah my my
thing with this is just I just I think
that like like pizza like the arguments
behind this like people not wanting to
download or another like a launcher
that's just ridiculous man and I can
understand I know undead in the chat
mentioned like the issues with Tencent
tension and I talked about this I don't
know how many podcasts ago Henson has
their tentacles and everything a little
bit of everything so a lot of what you
touch in video games it has it has
touched $0.10 in some way shape or form
so it's hard to avoid that for me
honestly the only valid argument that I
can see people making that I could I can
sort of agree with is because epic is so
new at this because it's there in this
simply because of the success of
fortnight you worry about that that
storefront being there in ten years that
is a valid point
like do I you're gonna make evening here
again and who says when fortnight you
know cuz obviously every game has a peak
every game has a Down inspired it's like
you know who knows from ten years from
now fortnight's here and if you're even
relevant at that point because you lost
your Golden Goose like I can get that
right right like I can get that where
you're saying okay well I even have
access to my my game license you know an
excellent that's not the point of them
going into into this is because they're
trying to anticipate when fortnight
isn't the biggest thing around anymore
right they're trying to establish a
brand in PC like they're they're trying
to get to that point where they're like
you know steam doesn't see us as just a
store they sees as a competitor by that
time you know yeah like they they try to
get to that that that Microsoft and Sony
money before you know that you know that
that point where fortnight's not
relevant as as much as a you so I think
for and I will always be relevant to the
aforementioned concerts in the game I
find it funny that people like now they
like valve is being painted as like this
disc underdog that's being attacked like
and it's it's funny they're they're
getting in on the conversation
themselves because they know that the
pressures coming from all sides it's
like you know I don't know what's going
on with steam and you know when they
make negotiations and stuff like this
but you know people always want to sit
there and act like I literally had
someone argue with me saying that
competing isn't make it shouldn't be
buying exclusives it should be just a
$10 difference and I'm like competing is
bugging me let me get it let me get it
this is this has been all my my mind
Lord Derek man this this whole epic
store thing man oh I got a lot to say
look here's the thing that I have to
address first like let's get it straight
the average store is providing the dev
more money on the profit split right so
our favorite devs are making more money
that's correct right - then we got in
North America
like when Metro the epic story the game
is $10 cheaper for the consumer than it
is on Steam correct oh sorry to solve in
OH
so to solve in an attic I don't this
game is $10 cheaper per se is just to
cut but you're not the cut is more but I
heard in North America in the Metro on
the epic story explain now um for when I
was on press Start Allen said it was $10
to mash out there I wanna shout out the
Lord hold on we had a good of virtual
galley on this for - - only in America
though it's $10 cheaper so right off but
off top consumer saving money
devs making money so they're winning and
then the storefront itself is trying to
challenge team so I just don't
understand the problem like just off of
the developer making more money from
some in the consumer getting it cheaper
but the only thing I do emphasize though
is that okay the last minute nature of
it okay
you know if you had your heart set on it
and then
you know you find out two weeks before
release the game's gonna come out you
know on another platform
I get that aspect I get the the
frustration with that but at least they
are for the people who really believed
in it they're honoring the pre-order and
from my understanding you know they're
getting and the people who pre-order
they're getting it on Steam so you know
I think at the same token what kind of
Atticus saying like competition is good
you know do they legitimately need to
improve their store yes do they have to
improve the security features yes do
they have to have cloud saves yes all
those things but let's not act like
Steam from the very beginning when they
launch had all those features from the
beginning like that's the meanest piss
me off like you gotta allow them time to
grow now if they continue right and they
say like it they still don't add any
features right I'm with you bomb um do
what you got to do I just don't like
review bombing like this sense of
entitlement from gamers to just review
Metro one and two they have nothing to
do this why y'all review bomb in their
game like to me that like you just hurt
in the dev like that that to me is just
I can't respect that when you're adding
to the ark the argument that gamers are
entitled gamers are petty like oh and we
all have to we all end up falling under
the umbrella we all have to eat that
because of a select few and I mean it
just does the part that's bother me
because it's like I do listen should the
death threat in the gamer know who knows
I'm not saying that but at the same time
I understand its frustration like yeah I
don't know what it takes to make a game
y'all sitting there attacking it this is
beneficial to the studio like so there
could be future projects you know in the
future but here's the main thing though
and it kind of I want to tie back the
Xbox is like you know we hold the whole
thing Xbox has no games remembered I've
been holding the whole narrative so then
like member back solved when a Microsoft
secured the one year exclusivity for
rise of the Tomb Raider remember that
remember the tiki torches without the
tiki torches out and when that game came
out on PlayStation it kind of bombed it
kind of bubble here's the thing can I
interrupt for real quick I definitely
apologize I gotta go
that's cool but you know I appreciate
Lord day for coming by I'm Network and I
get laid I've delayed the working long
enough a pleasure talking to you you
know I hope the best for you and your
brain I love - and I played it actually
a kid smooth he raged it was funny but
you know look definitely look forward to
having you back on one day and it's been
a pleasure absolutely thanks I had a
cousin Larry's here the day way while
the cops go pass but um
yo that they got that woody is like
remember when the whole narrative with
Xbox and they need it you know they'd
have any games the Deuter odds of the
tumor anything you know to get the
one-year exclusive people go crazy this
is anti-consumer Microsoft you don't say
how dare you secure that for your thing
but my thing is I don't see the same
energy when other people get exclusives
like when Marvel Ultimate Alliance 3
just announced exclusive to switch I
thought that was a Power Move on a CD
tiki torches Street Fighter 5 exclusive
to PlayStation 4 thought that was a
Power Move I don't see you know the
thing destiny had maps and exotics
shunning PC and Xbox users for years
again I don't see it so it's like you
can't pick and choose you know I'm
saying
what you gonna tiki torch about you know
I'm saying because at the end of the day
if you really want that game go get the
platform console guys been doing it for
years like I just don't understand it
like I get it like at the end of the day
it's competition it's gonna force epic
to step their game up it's gonna force
these guys to step their game up you
know I'm saying and it just makes us as
gamers look bad and all you got to do
let's be real for all you gotta do is
click an icon on your desktop what's the
big deal I just click the second icon
like why is this torture down download
the game and after that you're playing
the game I couldn't understand some
issues like I said people said epic is
the storefront is in its infancy so
probably you might have some issues with
updates to the game and as that stuff
steam has gotten fixed over the course
of many years like didn't so it runs
smoothly in that regard but hey I mean
when Steve when steam came out it was a
steaming pile of trash it's but if you
wanted to play half-life 2 if you wanted
half-life 2 you needed that steam mmm so
you know it's just a matter of of
allowing the growing pain
being paged although all those other
arguments don't make a lot of sense to
me except for the fact that maybe you
won't access your game from there at
some point I can see that because you
can see it as wasted money but beyond
that and everything else is BS man like
it's just it's it's entitlement and and
and it and it feels like that's where
you really see the division between like
like you mentioned the console gamers
and PC gamers the ecosystems are so
different is so distinct right and the
expectations are have been so different
for so long this kind of this this sort
of attacking of the status quo with
something they're not prepared not
prepared for it not used to it whereas
console gamers were used to it and I
want to say last when shot the L bug in
a chat which I have to say this and I'm
not the biggest 49 fan but I gotta say
you we have to give credit to what
fortnight as a game and epic was doing
to the industry right now think about it
like fortnight really set the tone to
get Sony to play fair with cross play
right that's opening things up right now
you look at them because of the success
of fortnight now they're opening up
their own store the epic store not a
forcing competition they're getting
games like ashen and Excise and a metro
Exodus and division and like at the end
of the day Saint whatever side of the
fence you're on you can't deny the the
schism that that they are creating and
then what's going on in gaming our game
to change because of that one title and
that's kind of interesting to me but
that's all I got PD in a lord Derrick
you want to finish this up before we get
out of here sure I mean like I can I can
say one more thing about that I suppose
you if you met like who would be the
best company right now in the world to
do a competitor like epic have integrity
and they have resources to do it
they're serious about it like they're
pushing really hard to do it and they've
got like full focus on it like coupled
with like a long history in games like
they know what they're I can't imagine
like anyone else could could pull it off
as well as they can if you look at valve
I mean valve came from the same place
like a company was extreme integrity and
all that nice stuff making a thing like
this I think it's like the right people
and then add that to like the fact that
like a competitive marketplace is
generally a good thing doesn't seem bad
but they were gonna be growing pains
there's gonna be expectations dashed
just because like you know things are
changing and it kind of well so for some
people yeah
change is tough people you know it's
hard well you you used to things for so
long in one specific way you know it's
hard for people to adjust ma'am what uh
yeah I'm glad you are a good sport about
this topic it gets your truffle but I'm
glad that you're able to contribute
there because this was a hot one and um
like I said we definitely want to get
into it I'll solve an RP before we close
out and get the pole and get out of here
yeah I mean I checked quickly the game
is $49.99 on the epic store so um but I
think I mean isn't that a general thing
with PC gaming and steam in general you
usually get these games for at least $10
less than you would a console release so
I think that's about on par with what
you can expect right
ai ai ai ai I think that epic for some
reason why their games are a little
cheaper I don't know why but I've
started to notice that kind of a trend I
don't know if that's because of the the
way that the developers are getting but
could their cut or what but I have
noticed that but I've noticed that most
stuff on Steam is the regular standard
price gotcha
and at the end of the day like you know
we hope that you know that that benefits
the gamer Khatami cloud cloud power -
into the water
oh wait fashioned to look they can't
wait to get out of your bed all right
Lou I'll pee Paul this week in regards
to the recent controversy regarding
Metro Exodus move from steam and now to
the epic storefront do you consider this
latest exclusive deal by epic just
another competitive move the choices are
a know they are just buying third party
time exclusives anti-consumer B yes devs
make more money and consumer gets games
for cheaper win-win see I don't care
PC gamers are finally getting a taste of
that console war smoke
dad Oh question those are the choices
please Rock the ILP vote when it goes up
on Twitter tomorrow Lord Eric Bradley of
Aurora 44 studios and you guys gonna
have you in the realm of the Lord's Man
where can I find people find you and
what else do you have going on the best
place to find us is a full full games
you can find us on Twitter you can find
us on Facebook and on Instagram
definitely like website to April for
Gamescom yes absolute pleasure man just
hearing your passion and the knowledge
about this game and and learning the
whole design choices you guys made
really really humble to have to in Roman
Lords today learned a lot and learn
about your fearlessness man you believed
in this project man you really put
yourself out there you did it laughs
Peter Jackson you went on your own and
you create the souls series that
everyone loves the collaborative aspect
and we cannot wait to see an action to
or anything else you guys are cooking up
great studio and it was a pleasure to
meet you back at PAX hopefully run into
you again hopefully at 83 or one of the
next events yeah absolutely really good
to see you again it's been a pleasure
catching up with all you guys
likewise my class Lord addict Lord King
had to go and a little addict had to
work and looking at emergency he'll be
back next week Lord sovereign we're
gonna find people find you what you got
going on here
first of all shout out to the Lord Derek
for coming through really appreciate it
I absolutely love the fact that you'd
you know you were passionate about this
project and you chose passion over money
that's something I you know I I really
respect and I will always support that
and then anytime I could talk about
Cormac MacCarthy as a plus so thank you
so much for coming through we really
appreciate it
big shout out to Lord pd-2 for coming
through and holding us down you know I
got you guys you guys can find me on
Twitter Lord sob IOP and B X sovereign
on PSN and Xbox Live no doubt Lord
PD with the outstanding standing holding
us down today much appreciated Wieck and
the farmers kitchen what you got going
on man so a bunch of stuff going on so
it's now though in most of all of my
types of social media you know I am you
know policing the discord on a regular
basis this discord police so you know
may division to beta is supposedly
coming out this week I am going to be on
it
non-stop I am gonna be playing division
literally all week and as most of my
community knows from twitch February is
a fundraising month for myself so all
the proceeds I get from subs donations
and everything like that goes straight
to multiple different types of you know
fundraising type places this for
instance this time I'm going to be
putting all the money towards the LA
guinea-pig rescue um so uh if you guys
stop by donate some money from her for
those guys that over here man again
thanks everyone for sticking around no
Super Bowl Sunday we'll get you guys out
of here and yeah absolute pleasure Lord
Eric just to hear the stories again once
again and I'll make sure I said that
like subscribe all that good stuff you
know or Lauren Kyte also will have the
audio up on Spotify iTunes SoundCloud
and Google Play the links will be in the
description I'll try to get more Derek's
information as well you know in the
description again great turnout um also
I believe we have our ILP we have a
which called the last word show deep
artist that is currently up on the
channel please check us out for your
destiny anthem and division needs talk
about the latest state of the game and
of course I want to shout out the stream
team my man lost on PT here you know say
MJ is a boss so you had a chat today
l-boogie say in the chat old-school
stylez showed you the chat it was
awesome and of course lord de la
potentially perfect one himself please
support these guys they really do a
fantastic job when a stream team and
yeah man that's all I got so if anybody
has anything else we can enjoy your
Sunday root for your team but Super Bowl
Sunday and enjoyment
everyone have a go up please